Hello!
Hello everybody!
Oh my god, I don't know why I'm so nervous.
I don't know, today I've just been like butterflies.
It's my birthday.
Yes, my real birthday.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's, I spent, what a day.
What, what a fucking day.
All right.
So, um.
so um if you guys didn't notice we have new alerts now a
huge shout out to the dragoons for uh giving me some new
alerts we finally updated our our new alerts guys um so we
have member new alerts for members uh gifted memberships uh
super chats Akasupas and Streamlabs so all of those will be
uh will be new alerts uh coming in and uh oh my god I oh
thank you guys thank you all for all the uh birthday wishes
everybody I really really really do appreciate it guys um I
wish I have like more presents to give you guys um but I I
did tell you guys, I spent majority of the time in terms of
like projects and planning.
Um, it was mostly regarding my new skin suit.
So I know I haven't uploaded the wallpapers yet or the 3D
models, all that stuff soon.
This week, I promise you guys, this week, it was just a lot
of things back to back to back to back.
So I wasn't able to, um, upload all the stuff yet from the
skin suit debut.
But, uh, I would promise you guys that by the end of this
week, They will be uploaded.
And those are my gifts to you guys.
I also do have a special gift for you guys, though.
You see down there at the bottom left side.
At the bottom left side.
I do have some special gifts there.
It might not be as elaborate or like as big as previous
birthdays.
But like I tried my best.
There might be.
um some of you guys are like oh doki usually when a vtuber
uh when a vtuber has a birthday or a special thing going on
usually uh they will release a song or something um not
today but sooner than you think but also not as not as
professional as you think it is that's all i can say that's
that's all i can say about it So that's a belated birthday
gift, I guess.
That's a, it's gonna be a belated birthday gift because, um,
um, you'll see why.
You'll, you'll, you'll, you'll see why.
All, all I can say is that, um, no, I don't want to spoil
it.
Fuck, okay, I won't, never mind.
I won't, I won't spoil it though.
I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna spoil it.
That's all I can say.
I'm not gonna spoil it
Soon Sooner than you think.
I feel like Yeah sooner sooner than you think Oh my god.
I'm I'm just I don't know I'm just It's been a wild morning.
It's it's it's been it's been a very wild morning.
I feel like everybody expected some everybody guessed a lot
of people guessed correctly on you know the first
announcement for those who are not on also thank you
everybody for the super chats I really really do appreciate
it everybody thank you guys thank you for all the support uh
Lord Kurosus thank you for the Akasupa thank you thank you
uh happy birthday Doki take your time on all the stuff And
just know we appreciate so much.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
I really, really, really do appreciate it, guys.
So, like, for those who are not on Twitter, yes, everybody.
Okay.
You know how, like, it was so hard to keep this a secret.
Oh, anyway.
So, you know how I tweeted?
I was like, guys, 8 a.m.
And then people were like, what times?
I can't believe some of you guys were like, what times
those?
You guys?
I only work with one time zone.
I practically exist in PSD.
That is my go-to time zone.
I say so much about West Coast, Best Coast.
But it was so funny.
People were like, which time zone?
I'm like, what do you mean?
Which time?
You guys know my default is PSD, you guys.
That's my default.
Also, Dark, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Sama Final.
Thank you for the Aka Aka Aka Supa.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
I saw thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
Woo!
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
And Aphelion.
Thank you for the Akasupa too.
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
Looking forward to all the good things coming your way.
Speaking of good things coming our way, I do have several
announcements, but I have to stall a little bit because
there are, like, multiple announcements that I have to make
today.
Multiple really...
Oh, my gosh.
I know you guys were like, There's more announcements.
Yeah, I have to stall a little bit.
I don't know when I can make it.
I'm supposed to make this announcement too.
But like, well, several announcements.
There's already two that's confirmed already that I can
make.
But I won't make all the announcements at once.
So I'm stalling until like I get confirmation on the final
announcement.
Also, daddy, thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
I fucking, okay, not gonna lie.
I fucking love the alert at the bottom left.
like so um like even without the music i can hear it playing
and i could hear i could hear the song in my mind but okay
oh my god i could like hear the music oh my god anyway but
the announcements are unrelated to the gift box over there
so like you see that gift box this that gift box down there
is unrelated uh to the announcements those are like future
announcements those are more like gift announcements um
anyway uh oh my gosh okay so like you know how like yeah
early in the morning um uh i saw a lot of people that were
like like 8 a.m can you even wake up at 8 a.m true true that
Like, that's a, because even you were like, Yogi, why would
you pick 8 a.m?
For whatever secret announcement that is.
And I'm like, you think I would pick 8 a.m.?
Do you really?
You think I would willingly pick 8 a.m.
Like, no.
Basically, it was basically, the reason why it was 8 a.m.
Is because Anime Expo opens at 8 a.m.
And, like, all these stuff there, it was going to be shown
there.
Anyways, so they had to announce it before Adam Expo opens.
So, um, the funny thing is that, uh, um, so, like, the Hyatt
announcement, a lot of people guessed it correctly, because
they were like, of course it's going to be the Hyatt
announcement, because we already talked about it before.
And, uh, the thing is, sorry, and you open the door, because
it's like, I talk so much that there's so much hot air
blowing in that, like, it's so humid.
So, I'm like, I can't breathe.
I just, it's so hot.
um but anyway um so um so i suffered a lot of you guys with
waking up at 8 a.m to be fair i wake i actually woke up at 7
in the morning because like you know when you're so excited
uh when you're so excited and you couldn't sleep um so i got
like three to four hours of sleep last night because i was
just way too excited because nobody expected
Nobody expected the nendroid
Yes, I am going to be a nendroid
Oh my god No one, okay, some people were like Oh my god,
what if?
But like, I don't think in your heart You expected the
nendroid announcement I am also like in You know, it's It's
so hard to believe sometimes that it's so hard to believe
I'm gonna be I'm gonna be an an android um but yes coming
soon oh my gosh I I don't want I can't spoil what the
accessories are gonna be but um you guys are gonna love you
guys are gonna love what I pick for the accessories and okay
this is a really funny story okay okay so not story but like
um so i had i looked at the sheet so like when they propose
the nendoid stuff and they propose like the expressions and
the accessories it was so funny because i was reading the i
was reading the sheet and then in the notes it was like make
sure the mouth is slanted
and like for like all the face plates the notes were like
make sure the the smile is curved and slanted it is not
regular fate not regular smile it has to be slanted i
thought i was like it was like a like a bolded note on the
face plates and everything and um it was honestly um oh my
gosh Oh, I guess I'm just, I'm, I'm just out of words
because, uh, I'm not gonna cry, but I just want to say, uh,
thank you guys so much, Dragoons.
I don't think without you guys, I could even, the fact that,
like, I'm an indie VTuber, and not a lot of indie VTubers
get a chance to have a Nendroid, uh, because usually when
you think of Nendroids, it would go to, like, corporate, you
know?
So, Like, the fact that, like, I was able to be, like,
within, like, you know, the rare Indies that have the
opportunity to be a Nendroid, it is absolutely insane.
And, um, basically, um, they work so fast.
It, like, it was, they work so, because, like, it's...
not like this deal has been negotiated for like a long time
it was like I don't want to give I can't give details but it
was like much faster than I expected because um this was
actually arranged by this was arranged by my ain't my agent
and my new staff team so my agent and my new staff team
worked on the on on on getting me the Nendroid.
And, like, I remember they were like, they emailed them and
be like, hey, do you want to, you know, Doki really, really
wants to be a Nendroid.
And, like, yeah, she loves your stuff.
Like, are you open to this idea of making, adding Doki Bird
to the indie line, like, for VTuber, VTuber Indies with
Nendroid?
And they're like, yeah, like, of course.
Like, they're like, yeah, we really want to work with her.
And, um, and it, it, Oh my god.
It's just really hard to...
I can't believe they said yeah.
I can't believe they said yes.
And at that time, the original idea was to do my new skin
suit.
Because at that time, everything was practically done for my
new skin suit.
But then we decided...
like we talked about it and we decided to go with the old
skin suit um because uh because like we thought that like
you know it was like retro retro dokey was a big part of my
life and um and then that gives me opportunities to maybe in
the future if the cells go really guys hint hint hint if if
the cells go really really well for retro dokey we might be
able to get you know hint another nendroid uh you know
current current skin suit dokey
hint so you know have more than just uh more than just like
um one version of me um as a nendroid and so yeah so that's
why we decided to go with uh retro doki um and oh my gosh
like it's just i like when they were like they were like
we're gonna announce it at anime expo and i was like that's
soon i i legitimately expected it to be announced like end
of the year i did not think it would be like they're like by
the way we're gonna like if everything's good to go we're
gonna like uh we're gonna Like, let people know at Anime
Expo.
And I was like, I was like, what?
Wait, wait, I'm still like, I'm still living through the
rush of the fact that I'm a nendoid.
Oh, my God, it's just, I was not ready.
I was honestly, I was not ready.
all um uh but it's it's it was wild and then i told the
story at anime expo during my panel um and basically they
told me that uh the nendroid was gonna be announced at 8 a.m
so you know you know hyatt announced the uh announced the
thing at 8 a.m as well and so like i was like oh sweet like
so like 8 a.m passed and then I was like we we're just we're
just an android and everybody you know expected the hide
thing to be like the last announcement that was gonna happen
because I was like 8 a.m.
and like the hide the hide pc collab was like the only thing
that came out 8 a.m.
so then I asked my staff and I was like also lita thank you
for the akasupa thank you thank you happy birthday joki I'm
so happy to see you become such a successful vtuber hope we
can have you for many many more years thank you thank you
that really really means a lot um but basically uh so uh i'm
god so i messaged my staff i i messaged my staff and i was
like oh um staff where where where's the nendoid
announcement is it and then my my staff that's at anime expo
was like oh don't worry um they say it'll be 808 your your
your tweet is scheduled for 808 and i was like 808 okay okay
808 and then 808 i've been i was like refreshing the like
the good smile company twitter twitter accounts i was like
refreshing over and over and over again because i was like
where where i need it i want it i need see it like I need to
see it to believe it so so 808 passed and then 808 was Iron
Mouse's pop figure I was like this is not me this is B
shocho I was just like wait a minute did they think I'm Iron
Mouse this isn't me Iron Mouse is 808 I was like I was
like...
What?
Where's...
Where's Nandroid?
I was like, where's Nandroid?
I was like, wait, where's Nandroid?
808 was Vishojo.
And then my staff must reply back.
I was like, oh, sorry.
There's like two to three more Vishojo announcement.
And then it's your turn.
And I was like, okay.
Okay.
oh my god so I was like waiting in anticipation because I
didn't know the exact time I didn't know the um I didn't
know the exact time of like when it was gonna show up I just
kept refreshing and refreshing and refreshing and like
getting baited by my other announcements until like I showed
up and I was like it's there it's finally there it's real oh
my god it's real
um oh my gosh I was so I it was so hard to be patient you
know and then because like oh I was just I had no words I
honestly I I have no words I was just I'm there
real the one thing we're missing now is a funco pop when we
got when we get the funco pop then we've truly made it we
need a we need to complete the try force we have the u-to's
figure we have the nendroid all we're missing right now is
the funco pop to complete the triangle
um oh my gosh there were there were so many announcements oh
i guess oh like um so you guys didn't know um other than the
well i mean you guys should know because i talked about it
during the skin suit reveal but uh at anime expo and at the
um uh and at the like oh my gosh sorry it's so hard to talk
I'm just so I'm just so happy I'm I'm just really happy
right now so it's it's so hard to verbalize my thoughts it's
so hard to communicate right now um and you know I'm usually
really good at yapping but like today I'm just my mind is
like all frazzled and um yeah like
It's so hard to, like, word anything in my head today
because there's just, oh, there's so many things going on.
And I told you guys, July, July's crazy.
July is actually crazy.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you guys so much for all the birthday wishes.
I really appreciate it.
I just...
I never expect to get a nendroid.
That's really weird.
It was honestly like a dream of mine to get a nendroid.
I've been a nendroid collector.
Well, not recently.
I was a lot younger.
I used to collect a lot of nendroids growing up.
And, you know, it's just so surreal to, like, see me as a
nendroid.
And then, like, oh my gosh.
I'm just, like, thinking, like, Am I going to, like, go to a
random anime store and then I'm going to see me?
Like, like, I'm just thinking, like, oh my God, will I,
like, show up at some random anime store?
And then I'd be like, there's me.
Oh, it's actually, it's like, you know, like real life
sighting.
Like, you know, everything's for me is just virtual.
But to, like, see a wild dokey IRL is just, it's, gosh, it's
going to be.
so weird it's gonna be so fucking weird um so it is honestly
just oh i'm just i'm i'm so frazzled i'm so fucking frazzled
right now thank you all for the happy birthday wishes guys
thank you all for the birthday wishes and all the super
chats and the members and everything i i really really
appreciate it um i'm trying not to cry I'm trying, I'm
trying not to cry because, you know, I'm usually not used to
having so many things happening on my birthday, unlike my
real birthday, like, so, so it's been pretty overwhelming
and, um, ah, okay, I have to actually move on to the next
subject or I'm gonna actually, like, fucking cry or
something.
oh my god um it's just it's just crazy to say as an indie to
have an android as an indie and it's just like it's really
rare for for indies to get an opportunity like this so i'm
really thankful to my team and to my agent to one of my one
of my three my two agents um for helping me um accomplish
this and reaching out to good smile company asking if they
were interested and then people at the good smile coming be
like yeah let's do it and i was like really you're not
fucking with me right like so i'm just really happy you guys
are gonna love the accessories that i picked um that i that
i that i picked for an android you guys are gonna love it
like
um all right all right okay moving on moving on to the next
subject that i should be talking about by the way like i
said um the announcements will be at a later time uh because
an announcement and what's in the gift gift will be at a
later time um because i need to get final confirmation on
one of the final announcements so right now i'm just talking
about all the current announcements
Anyway, the other thing is, yes, it is up to four pre-order.
Uh, yes, okay, if one of my, if my, sorry, I know like, uh,
right now there's only one mod at the moment in chat, so if
my one mod can, can post a link to, uh, to the Hyatt
pre-order for me, and then I'll ping it, I'll, I'll pin it
right now.
Um, but yes, we have the Hyatt I Buy Power PC case collab
with Wall Scroll, uh, kitty caps, desk mat.
Um, if you order the, uh, limited edition, I said limited
edition.
If you order, oh yeah, it is.
If you order, if you order, if you order the limited
edition, you'll get like bonus stuff.
So like the bonus things are like stickers.
um it's like stickers cards and uh i'm trying to remember
everything that was in the bonus collection a charm there's
a lot of stuff there's so many things oh my god there's
there's a lot there's a lot of stuff um but i really want
you guys to know that uh for the i worked really hard with
hyatt and i to make it uh super personalized in a way that i
think you dragoons are gonna love i mean we'll love because
like you can literally see what's like in it um and i want
you guys i i'm i'm a keycap collector i collect keycaps i um
i love i'm i was very very very picky when it came to the
keycaps um well i'm sorry i dropped my cough drops um i was
very very like picky and uh uh stingy on like what the key
caps were supposed to look like um because like uh like i
said like i was very particular about it and like i as
someone that loves um what's the word called what's the word
uh the like symbols on key oh no guys sorry i'm my brain's
not working today guys my brain's not working today um but
the god what was that word called the the symbols on the
keycaps not the regular ones the what's the key what's the
key cap keycap words keycap keycap terminology G's you know
like the the the pretty I icons the novelties yes I'm sorry
my brain's not working today I'm really overwhelmed
everybody I'm super overwhelmed today um but the novelties
um so um the novelties uh for the keycaps I was very very
particular on what how it was supposed to look like if you i
don't know if i could show the first draft but like maybe in
the future i'll have to ask um i have to ask like the people
at ibuypower and hyatt whether or not can show like the very
first draft of the key caps or not but i requested like very
particular novelties um for this collection and like i had
like a huge hand in like designing a lot of these in terms
of like my vision and you guys can see there's a lot of
dragoons and everything because I want to include my
dragoons and like uh dad um and as as many merch as I can
because like you know With all my dragoons, I can't do the
things that I can do like I could wouldn't be able to
achieve the things Um that I've achieved without your
support So like I want you guys to like be with me on this
journey and like be with me on my merch and everything Like
it's not just like a me effort.
It's like a team effort guys remember we are a team So any
like mistake that I do it is a team So any mistake that I
do, we did together You can't just be in the positives of
the team, okay?
We are there for the negatives as well
Like, this is the positive part But, like, you guys have to
be there When we fuck up, too The shared liability Anyway,
anyway um um i'm gonna show you guys the key caps because
like i if you guys didn't see the key caps there's like
stuff i wanted to show you guys from the key caps so these
are the key caps and i want you guys to see down here uh you
can see that croaky is okay wait let me uh oh so by the way
i said i wanted the tomato for this right here okay oh my
gosh you're just like and you guys should see the tomato
right here i the tomato did not was not originally in uh was
not originally in it but like i requested to have like
tomato because i wanted the keycaps to be like everything
that i've represented like everything that you dragoons have
done everything that i have done in my career and uh in my
very short career of like six months but but like this
basically the keycaps is basically like six months of
history um streaming and so and then we have a tomato goon
too right here we have a tomato goon as well uh right here i
actually i requested that too i was like i need the tomato
goon and then obviously i i requested to have uh the dragons
in the keycaps as well and okay but i need you guys to look
at a particular
um keycap design also i love this this one they added in and
i was like this is beautiful but i need you guys to see this
uh okay okay so um croaky is in the uh keycap collection and
i need you
was such a last minute addition.
It was literally...
Okay.
It was literally added.
So last minute.
To the point where...
Because after I did the Kroki stream, I was like, Kroki has
to be in the keycap collection.
Like, Kroki has to be in it.
And it was so last minute that because we added Kroki in is
a reason why we don't have the samples at anime because they
were like it's too late we can't get the samples in time by
adding croaking we can't get it in time for the convention
so so that's why that's why there's no keycaps like shown
like physical keycaps shown um at the at the booth at it
because I demanded for crookie to be added to be added in
and um and um like basically like uh we were gonna add one I
was I was like oh I like sent screenshots of like crookie uh
pictures like to potentially be made into keycaps and uh and
then I was like you know you could pick any one of them and
then the staff at high it slash i by power loved the croaky
so much they were like let's add all four they're like fuck
it let's add more key caps in there we're gonna add all all
four croakies into the collection because they were just
gonna we were just gonna it was just one we were gonna just
add one but they're like no let's just add all four of them
so i'm really happy that uh i'm really happy because yeah it
was it was incredibly last minute I am just as shocked as
all of you guys that croaky managed to make it in like all
four of everybody's like one or two but croaky gets like
four I was like wow wow how come your mom lets you have four
croakies I don't how come how come they let you have four
croakies also my oshi mark is there too um but yeah Oh,
gosh.
It just looks amazing.
The collection really does look so amazing.
Like, look at the packaging.
Like, what the?
Oh, my God.
I love the packaging, too.
Like, the illustrations.
And I want to keep the box.
The box looks amazing.
And, what else?
And then there's, like, the keycaps, too.
Oh, this is the keycap box.
So it's more themed towards the dragoons.
Because, like, I'm on.
the i'm on the pc box but you guys get to be on the keycaps
box so like all the dragoons over here um and also the
packaging for that and oh yeah those walls scroll oh my gosh
the wall scroll look at that beautiful artwork i i wish i
could show you guys the drafts for it was so difficult to
pick um the artwork for uh the artwork for this because like
There was like three other poses and the reason why I picked
this particular pose was because of the dragoons because I
loved how the dragoons were positioned.
Because I was like, oh my god, the dragoons look amazing in
this one.
I don't care what I, I don't care about my poses, but the
dragoons look so good.
And that's, that's why I picked, I picked this one
particularly.
all the dragoons were positioned in the artwork so um that's
how i picked this particular pose in this particular like
arrangement um that's us um and then there's the desk mat
too so uh if you guys never had a dokey desk mat now's the
time to finally own a dokey desk mat it is oh my gosh it's
still it's really surreal to have like a gaming gear
collection in general because um you know it's it it's as a
gamer it's it's not something that i guess like i think i
would have and and it's i'm sorry oh my gosh sorry that was
like that's a it's just like it's just hard to believe like
that this is possible and especially keycaps and like a PC
case and everything like I've remembered in the past um I
would tell you guys like guys I don't think I'm gonna get a
PC case like
um I remember you guys would be like Doki you're gonna get a
PC case in the future you're gonna get it you're gonna get
it and I was like guys I don't know I don't I don't know
guys um and then it was also like one of the reasons why I
never upgrade like before rest in peace PC Koon but it's
also why PC Koon lived as long as he did because like I put
out hope that um I will one day earn a um a PC collab even
though PC Koon was dying was like you know it was dying for
a while even before six months ago it was dying for a while
and PC Koon lived way too long for like how little life it
has left because I've always hoped like maybe maybe I'll get
a PC collab one day and because I was like what if I upgrade
and then and then I get like a message being like we got a
PC collab for you and then you know I was always like i was
so paranoid because i'm like what if what if i upgrade and
then i get that message like that'd be such a waste of money
so um i held hope i held hope and it finally it finally
happened it oh my god it it finally happened and i'm i'm so
happy because it really does look um it really looks amazing
and i cannot wait to see uh so many dragons um all the
dragons not all of them because like i know it's very
expensive but like for those who are able to pre-order it uh
to be able to you know like show photos of the builds that
you do or like just show photos of your keycaps and uh and
like the desk mat and everything and like i said thank you
so much to Hyatt and I buy power with working with me on
this, especially as an indie.
It's really it's just really weird to be able to get all of
this as an indie because you know um um it's because you
don't really expect a lot as an indie because you don't have
like I guess like So to be able to accomplish and be able to
receive all these offers from companies, like companies
reaching out to us or we like reaching out to companies and
asking if they are willing to like, you know, collab or
sponsor.
It's so surreal.
It's so it's hard to believe sometimes.
It really is hard to believe.
um and that's why i have a million things going on because
it's like i'm like thinking like oh no like by next year
will i still have the similar opportunities again by next
year or like um i just want i guess like what's the word i
want to um take the chances as um as i get them when these
like chances are going to stop coming so i'm trying i'm sure
that's why i say yes to a lot of things because like i want
to take advantage of the fact that you know i'm able to do
all of this now um now and not have to like i so that like
you know i'd be like being able to experience these
opportunities uh and just being able to do all these amazing
uh things because of you guys So yeah, I'm so happy.
I'm really, really, really happy that all of these are
coming in.
And oh my gosh.
Okay, I need to show you.
I yoinked this from Twitter.
Whoever took this photo, thank you.
I yoinked this off of Twitter from you.
But this is basically what the display looked like.
So they had a little, like a birthday setup at the Hyatt
slash I Buy Power booth at Anime Expo and like this is what
it looks like um so yeah they even got a cake and everything
they got a cake and like there's like streamers and balloons
and you guys can see everything but the keycaps because of
croaky everything's here excluding the keycaps but
everything's here
you too can get a triangular pc just like me Infinity the
square hole Next scene, thank you for the Akasupa Thank you,
thank you Happy birthday, Doki, I'm so happy for you and
everything you've accomplished You come so far, and I can't
wait to see what comes next We're all proud of you, by the
way Base Iran ship Thank you for the Akasupa, thank you,
thank you Oh, okay, so Alright, this is a FOMO story But
like, I now have a new FOMO story So, if you're at a, I will
never tell this on stream.
So, it will die with me on stream.
But, but, if, if you're at a convention, if you're at a
convention, and you want more FOMO stories, I have a new one
now.
I have a new one.
I have two.
Guys, I did it.
Now I have two FOMO stories.
Let's go.
Andrew, thank you for the 50 gift of chips.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Um, why do you hate us?
Okay.
Because like some guys were like, but Doki, you haven't
announced any conventions in Asia.
Great segue.
How am I supposed to?
How am I supposed to, like, get those FOMO stories when,
like, all your conventions are in, like, Europe, NA, and
Australia?
Good question.
Good question over there.
Nice segue.
YouTuber fan number 13.
I will make my first announcement.
I'm still going to stall for the other announcements, but,
like, I think I can make my first announcement because this
one was, like, this one has been confirmed that I can
announce it.
you guys might have already saw the hints for it already um
but um i will be at malaysia yeah that's me that's me i will
be in malaysia for any any mangaki i'm so sorry when i'm
pronouncing right wrong sorry i said right but that's not it
i can't even prove i can't even word that correctly but i
will be at this convention on august 23rd to 25th oh my gosh
there will be actual uh there will be merch sold there as
well so i'm actually super excited um i saw previews of the
um of the merch that will be sold at uh this convention in
malaysia so oh my gosh i'm so excited for you guys to see it
uh but yes finally i can announce some of my asia
conventions um we weren't missing asia uh because we already
went to europe we already went to australia we went to na
both canada and the united states i'm very sorry
self-america but you really but like um for i don't know who
to like approach regarding like self-america conventions and
we haven't had any self-american conventions approach us i
I'm very sorry.
Latin America, bros.
But we have another convention to announce for the Doki
World Tour.
Yeah!
We are losing.
I can't come to Brazil if nobody requests me to come to
Brazil.
how do i go to brazil if i'm not getting requested um anyway
anyway this is um one of the many announcements um that i'm
going to be making today um because we had a really great
segue into this um regarding fomo stories and um really
really, really excited to go to Ani Mangaki.
I'm so sorry if I'm pronouncing it wrong.
You know my pronunciation is not great.
Am I pronouncing it correct?
I don't know.
I'm sorry.
oh my gosh.
Also, this other one that was confirmed to me that I can
announce about it.
is that I can't fully announce what it is but Dragoons in
Korea
Dragoons in Korea There is maybe something happening in
Korea soon as well
So there will be a special event in Korea as well so that's
another thing to look forward to can't really announce more
details about it because it's like that's the only thing I
could say that's literally it that's literally the only
thing I could say about that event I have no graphics for it
told you when I say world tour I mean it I mean world tour
guys I did say if I mean world tour it is a gonna be a world
tour I wanted to be involved in as many places as possible I
want to come to as many as many places as I can to meet all
the dragoons from around the world because because like you
know I never really had that chance in the past it was very
rare for me to be able to talk to my dragoons personally uh
just like you know like a more uh personalized talks with
dragons and being able to see that you guys are real and
like you're not like uh you're not like you know chat bots
i'm like oh my god they're real they're not fucking bots
they're hatch they're not ai like my mom didn't buy a
thousand ai bots to talk to me so that looks like i have
people in my chat they're real people They're actually real
That's why Okay Like truth be told I don't know if this is
like Similar to like Other vtubers but like I Personally
think that like Conventions I don't really In terms of like
the commit Because I also do like a lot of overtime as well
At conventions I would have it for like on my pre-ins fees
and everything um I will have like uh like a set time that
I'm supposed to end it off but I tend to go over time and I
tend to stay much longer than uh then like what is you know
what uh what was agreed upon um like officially uh because
you know I really enjoy meeting my dragoons and I really
enjoy talking to them and um just like having like
especially meeting greets and everything and um and I would
say that like I personally uh I think like in general like
if I uh I I definitely make more money if I if I just stream
versus like doing conventions in terms of like just like you
know just like super chat avenue and stuff like that or like
taking other like maybe if I have a sponsor stream at that
time or anything but um I don't care about that I I don't
care about like even then like we've like actually
negotiated with conventions like they're like oh we can't
that's like the appearance fee might be too high for them um
depending on like um you know like exchange rate and stuff
like that because my appearance fees is based off of uh u.s
dollars and um and um because of that you know certain some
places might not be able to afford like with the exchange
rate being fucked with every other country but the US dollar
I feel like every country but US has had like the currency
exchange rate is not doing great but unless you're from US
I've had moments where US US let's say um um other than your
no you have to see the exchange rate of euros versus us
dollars because like the euro is falling now compared like
the euro the euro is like falling too because i was sending
money over um because one of my friends um one of my like
friends like uh was like hey i bought you something uh and
uh but uh bought you something but like you gotta pay me
back and so i could ship it and i was like okay here and
then i was like wait wait it's not expensive what i was so
surprised i was so surprised because it used to be more
expensive so i was like oh my god it's happening it's I was
like, it's happening.
The euro is finally falling.
Not the euro, too.
Oh, my God.
I'm truly in the...
This is why I always ask for US dollars.
Anyway.
um wait me that's not good okay anyway um anyway as i was
saying um uh fuck okay so like even i would i have a
convention would be like oh i don't think like um the
exchange is really high for this type of appearance fees it
was us dollars like i'm very i told my staff team that i'm
very open to negotiate regarding appearance fees um just
because like like i said like um honestly like my top
priority is meeting my dragoons from around the world and um
so you're doing meeting greets and doing panels and doing
like all sorts of things um at the convention i don't make
much um i put a lot more investment into it uh even despite
like um how like you know if we this i tend to go over time
um just because like i feel like uh you just i don't know i
just want you guys to have a great experience and you know
it's very rare to be able to have this opportunity uh
especially like uh especially like meet and greets because
like in meet and greets it's like you know it's very hard
sought like you guys fight for it like
you guys fight for the slots so like that's why like i i
remember in like afcon i went like um i went like an hour
plus overtime because there was like uh there was it was
like uh what was it called it's just lined up it was not
paid or anything it was just lined up and then it there was
still a lot of drag wounds there and then i was like they
were like are you okay with going overtime i was like yeah
yeah of course yeah everyone i think like but then on i
think like i remember it was day two and then my my staff
member was like okay Doki like uh you went overtime like uh
on day one but like we don't want your voice we don't want
you to burn out we don't want your voice to um get because
like at that time my voice was starting to die a little so
then my staff member was like okay we got a cap for the
second day though my staff member was like okay we got a cap
for Doki because like she can't do that twice because uh we
don't want she has like she has dopamine right after it was
also because like i also had like docu me right after that
too uh so so they're like we can't get overtime for day two
docu you're sorry you have docu me uh you have to sleep
early so you can make it to docu me as well so so i'm sorry
that we have to cut the line on day two um but uh it was
great okay i'm just really happy to be able to do all these
conventions Um, I can't wait to do many, many, many, many,
many, many, many more!
I want it for you guys.
And, yeah.
Um, all right.
So, what else?
I have, like, other stuff to talk about.
There's still, like, a couple of more announcements.
There's...
There's still, like, a couple of more announcements to go.
Okay, let me see.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm just...
It's...
Ah!
It's my birthday.
I'm gonna give me a sec, guys.
I'm gonna open the, we'll open the window because it is
getting, like, really lots of hot air.
I'm talking so much!
I'm yapping so much!
So I'm gonna open the window real quick.
I'll be right back.
I mean, I'm still here.
You can hear me from far away.
I need to open my window.
Alright.
There we go.
I think it's also because like super nervous today like i
have so much butterflies going on in my stomach so like i
feel uh i don't know i just feel a lot more like nervous
today and it's just a lot of excitement and everything
because oh it's just there's so many announcements there's
so many announcements to do there's so many things to talk
about um and it's it's crazy it's really crazy um okay all
right okay you know what i can show you one of the gifts
well we'll do one of the gifts too like we're it's like i
don't want to overwhelm you with like announcements back to
back to back
So we're gonna like, we're gonna like, um, make sure that,
like, we pace ourselves a little bit when it comes to these
announcements.
So let me bring the gift box over.
So, as you guys can see, we have a little present.
A little present for you guys.
All right, so I hope I bring out the right present.
I hope it's the correct present that I'm going to open.
So I have a special gift for you guys.
I have a special gift.
I have several special gifts.
Well, several as in two.
But, like, I guess, like, there's a third one.
But it's not, like, in the box.
Because, like, it's, like, more so of, like, a verbal
present.
So, whoa!
Immersion.
Alright, let's see.
I hope this is the correct.
Is this the correct one?
Oh, my gosh.
your soul oh yes this one all right i'm gonna make sure i
grab the all right so so so you know like um for birthdays
for birthdays um you know how there's like birthday merch uh
so this won't be
the reason being is that um i know like oh you put it out
today you're you know a lot of dragoons are gonna buy it and
everything um a lot of merch is being brought out now
there's the u2s there's the u2s there's the uh the hyatt sub
there's the nendroid okay nendroid's not pre-orders not out
yet but you know what i mean there's a merch coming out in
general especially Hyatt the Hyatt collab is very expensive
so um I decided um that I'm gonna wait a little bit uh so
that you know I want you guys to spend money on yourselves
and you know like be able to you know save money and
everything and so it was like that's also why I haven't
released the Battlebirds merch as well.
And as long as, like, pay rent.
Because, like, $300 plus dollars, it's a lot.
It's a lot.
Especially if you convert it to other currencies.
Especially if you convert it to other currencies and
everything.
I felt, like, $300 plus, it is a lot of money.
And, like, I'm not here to really make...
Like, I don't want here to be, like, profit, profit, profit.
even if you pre-ordered this on my birthday it's not gonna
arrive on my birthday because my birthday is gonna be over
in a couple of hours so I felt like you guys can wait a
little longer since like when this is like when this comes
out um you know uh when like people actually when people if
you order today it's not even gonna arrive today so that's
why um but I did want to show you guys birthday merch plan
but um i decided that uh i wanted to like uh pace the merch
line more um due to the fact that you know we have the the
hyatt collab pre-orders came out today and uh there's so
many other merch stuff and everything and also i just i
literally just sold the acrylic stands and everything um so
uh that's why i decided not to sell uh the birthday merch
today um it'll i also want to flesh it out a little bit more
um but yes there will be a limited set of these as well
where i'll be sending like a signed copy of this because i'm
planning i'm deciding at the um because like i decided not
to sell it i'm trying to like finalize and put more care
into my birthday merch as well um but i do have plans to
make a limited like there's a limited edition set and
there's a normal set the limited edition set will be signed
and the normal set will be like you know just
and so yes that is why i decided not to put the birthday
merch up yet um just because like i said there's a lot of
things being sold under the dokeybird brand and i don't want
to like you know i'm not here to be like i'm not here to be
like give me all your money it's all like i you guys support
me so much already and because of that i like i said i
didn't want to i didn't really want to uh force you guys to
like spend more regarding regarding this but isn't it cute
you guys are all in there too i requested every dragoon um i
requested every dragoon to be a part of the birthday um the
birthday merch like the birthday illustration and uh so like
you see that like you know there's the long goon there's the
egg goons with the little party hats there's chunky goons
there's a regular goons and everything and there's dad down
there at the bottom right there's dad dad um so uh so yes
this this is one of the gifts um that's in this box putting
it back into the box you go all right put the lid back on
too all right there's more presents but uh but i'm gonna put
it aside for now and because i want to talk about other
things i'm gonna paste my announcements guys so i am pasting
my announcements so shrinking the putting the box back here
again uh there's a lot more other gifts there's like two
more gifts in there too uh to look forward to uh but i'm
gonna put it away for now all right whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa oh my god i'm trying not to like be too overwhelming to
you guys i also saw like tweets also the other reason you
guys are like my wallet please don't keep my wallet oh my
god okay funny story by the way the minecraft server stream
is a public stream The only, like, exclusive part of it is
the fact that it's only members will be whitelisted to be
able to join the Dragoon server.
But the streams itself is a public stream.
Okay, but funny story.
So, apparently, there was, I think, 12 of you guys that
broke into the server.
So, or 15.
Okay, yes, apparently 15 of you guys broke into the server
before the server was supposed to launch.
And I only found out because you guys, like, posted pictures
of it on Twitter.
So, like, you know, after, like, behind the scenes work, I
was, like, looking through Twitter.
And, like, I saw my For You page of people taking
screenshots.
Shots of the server being like I beat the ender dragon.
We beat the ender dragon and I was like What is this my
minecraft server?
I said so in two hours you guys beat the ender dragon in two
hours Guys this supposed to be like a a multi-month project
anyway um so I messaged my um I messaged my uh uh the
Minecraft team and they were like what the fuck even they're
like that's not supposed to happen and and then uh I
messaged the team the Minecraft team and they're like we're
so sorry like we don't know why the whitelist just didn't
work and so like so they apparently one of them like went in
and kicked all of you guys out and the world is is reset now
but they reset everything so don't worry like you guys can
beat the ender dragon again in two hours like anyway
um anyway everything is reset now so you've lost all your
progress you have to do it all over again that's what you
kept breaking in um so um anyway so the server is fully
reset now everything is reset like all stuff you had in
there is gone so uh the ender dragon is back um and
everything uh but yes they fixed it the whitelist works now
um i don't i didn't know the whitelist didn't work i was
already whitelisted so like how was i supposed to know that
like when i joined in i thought assumed the whitelist was
working because they told me uh yo yeah you're whitelisted
now but apparently for some reason it just stopped working
but at least it was 14 of you guys so you guys were like
literally the beta testers or it's like it's like those like
um what is it called those like hackers that do it for good
like they're just hacking the show to them like oh your data
is compromised like we only hacked you so we can tell you
that your data um your security is compromised and like uh
we want you to improve your security yeah yeah i was like i
was like what the what do you i was like what do you mean
you beat the ender dragon and i looked through the tweets
they're like we got into the minecraft server two hours
later we beat the ender dragon i'm like And I was like,
what?
What do you mean you beat the Ender dragon?
Drow, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Bye, tomato.
Thank you, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, guys, I'm going to use the bathroom real quick.
Give me a sec.
I'll be right back, guys.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
Bathroom break.
Stay hydrated.
All right.
I'm back, everybody.
Oh my gosh, it was okay.
So yeah, so that was I can't believe you guys I can't
believe you guys looking broke into the Minecraft Sarah
Frank.
Like what the fuck?
Oh my god All right, I actually wrote notes on like just to
be like, okay, remember to talk about this and then remember
to talk about that and then remember to talk about this
Okay, let me see I'm looking through my notes just to be
sure that Uh, just to be sure that I got, like, majority of
stuff that I want to talk about.
Ah, okay.
Okay.
Um, I guess, like, I can do my second gift.
I guess it's time to give you guys the second gift.
All right, I'm bringing the present back.
All right.
So, this gift is unfinished, though.
Um, it's not done yet, but I wanted to show you guys.
uh the preview of it um i'm gonna do like gift two and three
uh so the second gift and then a third gift and then maybe
by that time i can make my final announcement i don't know
if i installed enough
um but yes here is my uh second gift oh this is the correct
one no what did i move what did i move oh this is what is
that what is that oh that's it okay that's something else
okay i was like what was i moving wait where did it go sorry
i'm gonna mess a little bit all right where the fuck did it
go where did okay i'm just gonna i'm just gonna resize it
sorry i kept the immersion stops here because i'm just gonna
reset reset the transform there it is yes it is another one
okay so some of you guys were like what is that this oh my
gosh the immersion
this is an uh this is an artwork drawn by my mama my mama
drew this i thought about whether or not to make this as
merch but uh because I am already releasing like uh the
birthday merch uh soon TM um I guess I wanted to paste stuff
um um I will be releasing this for free whenever it's done
uh so you guys can make it merch of it yourself you don't
have to like buy this as a merch um so I will be releasing
this for free whenever it's done um since already i mean you
guys are gonna be since already planning on releasing like i
don't want like two prints like so this whenever my mama is
done with this illustration um it will be free uh for all
dragons to download um in the future it won't be like
paywall or anything um i will be releasing this for free
just Like, I already have, like, the birthday merch print
and everything.
Um, I just didn't feel like I needed to uh, really, uh,
like, you can make it merch as for yourself.
Like, I don't like, I don't really mind.
You're like, Yogi, wanna pay you!
That's what BattleBird's merch is for!
We're, like, we're, like, coming up with a huge line for
BattleBirds.
Like, we're gonna make an art book and everything.
Like, a hardcover, limited edition art book and stuff with,
like, text and like notes and everything from all the people
that went like made it and then we're gonna have like a
special merch being made for battle birds that's what battle
birds is for like i don't want to like spam you guys with
merch because like like like you guys gotta look after your
wallets you know you guys i want you guys to like you know
have enough for rent and uh food and the internet because
like without the internet how are you gonna watch me um so
that's why and i know shipping is crazy expensive too so
like that's why like I'm pacing my my merch in general um
just because like you know I don't really um like I know
like merch is a lot of profit but like I'm not here for like
insane profit like I'm just here to have a good time
like I don't want to fucking bleed you guys dry like what
the
um just casually what we talked about the art book before we
talked about it during the behind the seat what do you mean
i dropped a bombshell like we were talking about the fucking
possibility of making an art book regarding the production
behind uh battlebirds like it's not like i didn't confirm
okay it's confirmed um we're like i'm like scouting like
we're i'm like scouting out like a um like a person that can
publish art books and stuff um like self-publish art books
um because there's just so many amazing artwork and uh work
in progress and concept art that went into the
um so that's why like uh that's why like it's gonna take
time um to like have all that plan and when because like i
don't want to like rush it as well i want merch that is
something that you guys really want and um there's quality
going into it i'm not gonna read like i'm i don't i don't
want to reuse illustrations for like 500 different types of
merch and stuff i like having like for like a unique certain
merch line so like um like this illustration will be for
this merch and uh this illustration will be for that merch
because I like to put like care and thought into it I feel
like I don't want to reprint it for like various other
things um because like that's not as somebody that like
collects stuff like as a consumer I rather have quality over
quantity just because like i want the merch to have special
meaning uh especially like when i'm putting thought into it
i like having because as someone that used to sell at artist
alley like i um i like having special meaning when it comes
to like what merch is speaking of like future merch i did
not i hope like uh the artist is okay for me oh my gosh i'm
so excited to show you guys this one okay speaking of like
merch with special meaning and making like a special merch
for certain things uh okay i don't know when this will be
done because we're still designing the concept of it but
like uh sorry oh my gosh sorry i ruined the immersion let me
put the lid down let me put the lid on this real fast um all
right i'm putting it behind me it's a little crooked this
lid let me okay there yeah i know you guys would be like
super annoyed at the crooked lay But, oh my gosh, I need to
show you guys this one.
This was not part of my announcements, but like, I really
wanted to show you guys this.
Okay, let's see.
Is this...
Okay, wait, whoops, not this one.
Sorry.
Give me a sec.
I need to like...
It's so hard to put away the presents, guys.
Wait, I need to save it.
Okay, I need to find it.
I'm sorry if the...
Look, I'm...
I'm sorry if like...
uh uh
but it's like um um because like um i don't think the artist
knew i was gonna show this
but i i really i thought it was a really good segue because
fuck yeah i'm spoiling you guys it's my birthday but like
we're a team so i'm gonna spoil you guys I saw some people
saw the guard field.
Guys, if you're gonna buy a You're gonna buy a toky bird
Nendroid and you also have the Garfield Nendroid.
Can you like Take a picture of the two of us together?
Okay, I need to show you guys this.
I need to show you All right, so I'm super excited.
I don't know when this will be done but like when it is done
when it is done i'm super excited to make this merch because
i feel like you guys would love this um the
dokey coin is going to be real there's gonna be a heads
version i'll assume this is his the tail side but you know
like those like coins like those giant coins and everything
um like the with them blah blah and blasting and stuff um
those coins we're gonna be making a dokey coin um and we're
currently i'm currently uh currently it's like in the draft
stages at the moment um but this is something i thought that
you guys are gonna i thought you guys are gonna love um but
yes it's gonna be like an actual coin coin like those giant
novelty you know those giant novelty coins you know what i'm
talking about with like textures and everything like those
like uh those like textures on the gold and stuff yes coin
will be made like a physical a physical coin um and not like
the tying coins like the bigger ones so uh it's gonna come
with like a box and everything um so yeah yeah like a
medallion yes similar to a medallion um and i don't know
when this this could be take like months or whatever but
when it's when we finally figure this out when the design
for heads is done as well um i'm definitely going to um i'm
going to like uh you know like uh we'll give like pre-orders
up for this but i'm super excited for this merch like i said
like i want to like play around with like merch like now
that like you know having um the choice to like this like
have creative control of like what to make and stuff like
that um i'm super excited um really really excited Anyway,
um, let me see.
Uh, I'm gonna, like, message the staff team to see, like,
uh, see, like, if I still have to...
If I still have to stop regarding the final announcement.
Okay, the funny thing is that, um, my staff team, uh, sent
my Asia team, sent me, like, a long list of, like, okay,
this is the final two announcements to make.
like okay but we need to make sure that you can make this
announcement and i was like okay it was a long list like it
was like they're like here are the talking points and i was
like wow that's why i was like i was like there's more
that's why yesterday i tweeted out i was like there's more i
was just like what oh my god i'm just like what do you mean
there wait there's more stuff to talk about
Thank you.
Happy birthday, Doki.
I really appreciate it.
Okay.
Um, the third gift is a spoiler for, uh, the next...
Oh, wait.
Sorry.
I forgot.
I'm gonna, like, uh, give you guys a cliffhanger.
I forgot to message my staff team.
Okay.
All right.
Next one!
Okay.
The third gift is a...
Wait, I need to hydrate.
I need to blow my nose.
Give me a sec.
Give me a second.
I need a moment.
So,
what do you mean?
How is this eating?
You guys, you got fed.
You guys got overfed.
You can't call it evil anymore.
You guys literally got overfed.
I don't even know.
Anyway, um, the next, uh, oh wait, the next gift that, um, I
wanted to give you guys,
is that, um, I was in talks, um, with, um, okay, give me a,
guys, give me a second, I'm gonna, uh, I'm joking, I'm
joking, um, anyway, Anyway, so, basically, I was in talks
with Tempo, and if you guys didn't know, Tempo is, I guess,
like, you can say, one of the few, many big organizers of
Apex tournaments and Apex events.
You know, how he gets, like, huge prize pools and everything
for Apex events and everything.
Like, you know, he has done, like, 25K prize pools to, like,
100K from all the way to minimum 25K to maximum, like,
150,000 US dollars for prize pools and stuff.
And we've always had these talks.
We've always had these talks.
And I was like, because, like, he always wanted to host
something for VTubers.
um this last this week um we were talking about it i was
like do you want to do it like for my next event and um we
are currently uh i think we had a date established too we
were so uh this will be a spiritual successor of sorts um uh
it's not gonna be a tournament it is gonna be a custom We
are planning on Oh my gosh, I need to bring up Okay, give me
a second I need to pull up my tempo chat logs Because he
gave me dates And I was just like I already forgot There's
so much stuff going on It It would either be On September
28th Or October 5th We've established like Dates for it I'm
announcing it now because we are gathering interest right
now because um participants will be invite it'll be invited
participants as in we'll be inviting like I guess like quote
unquote team captains but it's a custom so if you guys don't
know it's not gonna be tournament it's not gonna be
screaming um it's gonna be like fun match serious match fun
match serious match won't be like currency it won't be money
but the prize pool will equal a lot of money as in like the
prizes will because like maybe like one of the fun matches
like oh and like the maybe we'll have like one will be like
hide and seek match and like the team that the team that
hides the best like the team that survives in the end will
win a pc like each person gets a pc or like a 4080 Stuff
like that.
Like, or like an exclusive, like, Apex Legends, like, merch
or something that, like, you can't get unless you're, like,
a content creator.
Um, or, like, like, it's, like, a really expensive, like,
we're in talks at the moment.
Obviously, uh, the bigger interest this event will get, this
custom will get.
The bigger, the, um, we, we, the bigger sponsors, um, the
bigger sponsors we can have, uh, to provide better prizes.
Each game will have its own trophy and its own prize.
So, like, each game, everybody type.
And then every participant will receive, like, a little
memorabilia, similar to WrestleTuber.
I talked to Tempo, and we were, like, should we gather
interest privately or publicly?
I decided to make it public that plans are in motion.
Because the prizes gets more, I guess the prize pool and
budget and sponsors are more lucrative.
The higher interest we get.
And the more interest we get from VTubers.
This custom will be open to NA and APAC VTubers.
It will only be VTubers.
And, uh, it has to be, like, full-on, like, like, B-tubing,
like, uh, type deal.
So, the reason- I'm sorry at EU.
I'm really sorry at EU.
I'm really sorry at EU, but we had to make a decision on
NAEU or NA-A-PAC.
Due to server's issue.
So, we decided to make it.
We had to make a very tough decision.
We were guiding, like, the VTubers that will be
participating.
It's not V-Cykeel.
It is a 4-fun...
fun custom and similar to like it's just for fun we're gonna
have more fun matches than serious matches because we have
so many customs we have so many tournaments that's like
super serious and everything and i told tempo i was like i
don't want like prize money for this like i don't want
people to win prize money i want like prizes because i feel
like when you do prizes um when you do People tend to make
it more fun in general and not take it as serious as money.
So that's why some of them will be more like fun prizes,
like maybe plushies or like Apex plushies or like maybe one
of them will be like a computer.
The serious one will be a computer.
But each team that wins a game in this custom will receive
like a little bit.
like medal or a trophy it depends I'm like still working all
the details out at the moment um like I said like uh this is
still like in the works so now we're just getting interest
we're garnering interest to see like who wants to like to
see like participant who might be interested in it um
because uh I'll be like um I'll be inviting people to see
gather interest by inviting vtubers and like i don't want to
make it full-on centric like apex vtubers only can join this
is why i'm focusing heavily on the fun aspect of it um
because uh i wanted so that the fun aspect so i'm opening
invites to people who don't normally stream apex or are not
very great at FPS just for the sake that you know people
tend to not play FPS might really enjoy the melee you know
the melee only or like only meleys and stuff like that um
and yeah so that is my next event um I don't know what to
call it yet uh like I said like Temple and I were literally
talking about this this week and i decided to use my
birthday to announce the my next event um just like in the
past i want to use my birthday to announce the the next
event that that is in the works at the moment how do you
guys know like shibuya how is definitely like one of my role
models um as well as amelia watson um shibuya how for his
amazing like organization skills when it comes to like
tournaments like the Shibuya Hale customs and everything um
he has been like a great big role model and inspiration to
me when it comes to organizing organizing tournaments and
events the fact I was able to do that and like make a um
make a I guess like image and like um presence for himself
regarding um FPS games in general and being able to organize
like uh all stuff um and having a team behind it like his
like v psycho stuff is so famous in japan to the point that
like when i was in japan i would see like v psycho merch
being sold with like uh regular apex merch like in a mall
like i felt like at that point like like that's like crazy
to think about um of how like how shibuya how is like had
made such an impact when it comes to um when it comes to um
and like just like events as well like CR raccoon like see
you can see like oh there's like crazy raccoon events that's
like organized by like an entire company and shibuya hal is
like a person like a singular like you know you say crazy
raccoon tournaments in Japan and crazy raccoon tournaments
the whole image behind it is like uh the org itself but like
um I think like Chibuya has does have teams behind him but
he does do a lot of work uh behind the tournaments as well
like he started organizing these tournaments himself to
point i grew so big in japan that like his merch is sold in
like his merch is sold in like malls and stuff like um you
can see it being placed right next to like regular apex
stuff and like uh other like famous like anime merch and
everything and so he's like an incredible inspiration for me
when it comes to like organizing FPS tournaments and
everything.
Like I got a lot of inspiration from the stuff he's done in
the past.
As well as like for Ami.
Um, I've talked about this a lot in the past.
So it's not like, oh she's mentioning Ami for the first
time.
No, I've talked about it a lot.
Um, but yeah, like, um, uh, i feel like she's really great
at organizing things and like was such a pioneer when it
came to like what a singular vtuber can do and like in terms
of like hosting events and hosting like uh projects and
everything um i feel like i wouldn't have been able to uh
organize the things i've organized without like um the fact
that amy inspired me a lot to do these types of things uh to
see her motivation drive uh when she started and like
pioneered a lot of stuff within the vtubing community um so
i wouldn't have been able to do all this without like uh her
taking the first steps um first steps in starting these big
projects herself um so yeah and um also like i know it's how
like crazy raccoon has also done so much too regarding
organization and stuff and um they've Like, they're really
great at organizing tournaments.
And I really wish that we do have more of these types of
things in the VTubering community.
And I'm really, I hope that, like, you know, this Apex
custom will go well.
I hope, I do hope this Apex custom will go well.
We're still, we're still, like, drafting it up and
everything.
Like I said, like, Temple was telling me, like, we need to
gather interest.
and see who's actually willing to commit to it.
Um, to, to approach sponsors and everything.
Um, to be able to approach sponsors and, like, get, like,
the definite prize pool of everything.
So, yeah.
Yeah.
Um, all right.
Let me look at what my staff said.
If I can.
Uh, okay.
So we're still starting.
All right.
Before, okay.
I'm going to start one more time.
One last time.
Uh, new goals.
This is something I wanted to do.
So, this is why I want, the final song.
If it's not ready, I will announce this last thing another
time.
If by the time I made the goals list and it's not ready, I
will announce the last thing another time.
okay all right no there's more there's one last announcement
there's one there's one last announcement
okay all right new goals this is why i told you guys um i
don't want to make a new goals list until until like a lot
these things got announced because uh because then i would
spoil the goals that i've accomplished behind the scenes i
was like because i was like you know my previous goals it
was like oh i want uh no the apex custom was not a star it
was a gift a gift to spoil you guys what the what my next
big event was gonna be so like we're not gonna have like
event announcement like what they so like by the time by the
time we're at a stage where we're like the of the event
announcement for this apex custom it's not gonna be like
secret we'll have like a full-on like logo and everything
ready in like a stream to announce teams and everything
anyway like i said um um i didn't want to do the goals list
until uh on my birthday because in previous goals list i
wrote i want to figure well i want to figure i want a
nendroid well It would be awkward if I didn't put that again
before the Nendroid announcement.
So I waited until majority announcements were made.
So we can have an actual real goals list gone.
Oh, fuck.
I just remembered there was another goal in there that we
accomplished that hasn't been announced.
That's...
it okay jk there's actually like one more goal in there that
uh that we accomplish behind the scenes but i can't say
because now now it's time for you guys to figure it out
now it's your turn to figure it out what it could be also
i'm gonna tell my staff that like I'm gonna stall for 30
more minutes If I If in 30 minutes I had a very long day
today I started my day at 8 a.m
I'll stall for 30 more More minutes Okay 30 more minutes And
then I stream
all right okay so this is definitely one that we all know
that I really want to do um let's see we okay shit okay give
me a sec guys I'm gonna I'm gonna disappear real quick on
screen because like I'm gonna type like numbers and then
you're gonna see like a million toggles go on so I'm gonna
disappear for like one second don't be like where did Doki
go Where is she?
Give me a sec, guys.
Okay, there you go.
All right.
Okay.
I just gotta make sure.
All right.
Poof.
I'm back.
All right.
This one.
One million subscribers.
I, I, I'm tired.
I can't even spell right now.
Stabbers, before end of 2024.
Actually, I don't even know if that's possible anymore.
I don't.
i don't know it's actually a little scary because like i
don't know it'll suck if we don't hit it it would actually
really suck because people like well failed goal
so um i'm scared i'm worried try like before end of january
Okay, here we go.
I gave us a little bit of leeway.
Just a little bit of leeway here.
So, one minute before end of January 2025.
Don't sit.
Fine.
Okay, before end of 2020.
If you guys were so, you guys are so confident.
All right.
One minute subscribers.
before end of 2024.
That is my new goal.
Another goal.
I would love to have a Funko Pop.
Funko Pop.
Do you hear that?
Guys, Funko Pop.
I'll be your first VTuber.
Your first VTuber Funko.
I'm marketable.
I think.
I mean, I have an Android.
I should be marketable now.
Right?
The final try.
I need to complete the triangle.
I have the U-2s figure.
I have the Nendroid.
I need to complete the triangle.
I'm missing.
I'm missing the Funko Pop.
We need to summon.
Like, how am I supposed to complete the summoning circle
without the Funko Pop?
We have the Normie audience.
We have the flesh.
We need...
Okay, we have the Flesh Tube, because YouTube's, there's a
lot of, like, the YouTube, the YouTuber, sometimes, like,
Flesh Tuber audience.
The YouTuber slash Flesh Tuber audience.
We have the Otaku slash anime audience.
And now, we need the Normie audience.
We need the Funko Pop.
This is how you summon Doki.
We're literally, we're literally...
seeing the funco pop anyway uh but yes that is one of the
two goals that i really do want to uh i feel like no it
would not ruin it would it will not ruin the magic circle
because if we get a deal with funco pop then i'll have like
so many versions of me like we'll have we'll have enough
funcos to make an entire circle we're gonna have a flocked
version of doco We're gonna have the like one foot tall
Funko Doki.
We're gonna have the metallic Doki.
We're gonna have the We're gonna have the feminized Doki
bird.
We're gonna have the We're gonna have
We have so many guys the moment we get that Funko deal We
will have so many alternate versions of Doki.
We're gonna have the glow-in-the-dark Doki.
We're gonna make Get the entire circle with Funko Pop.
Think about it, guys.
And then the Normie audience.
Look, guys, the Normie audience is going to be like, we have
to collect all the dokees.
Okay, guys.
This is how.
Doke, I thought you said you're not for a profit.
This is like such a capitalistic thing to do.
Okay, look.
I make exceptions.
And that is for Funko Pop.
my one exception is for funko pop because i want all the
different alternatives when it comes to funko um all right
anyway other goals oh my gosh where did my goals let's go oh
no oh there it is okay i think this is it yeah no that's not
it oh no where did my goals let's go oh here it is okay
Anyway, that's like, uh, and then we get featured in the
Funko Pop game alongside Funko Freddy Fazbear!
Exactly!
That, that's, that, you know, how capitalism works.
All right, now we're gonna get a pro player to use my merch,
uh, to use my gaming, gamer gear on...
in a tournament.
Guys, please somebody get good so you can bring Joachimers
to a tournament.
That's all I want.
Okay.
That's one of my goals.
Another goal that I have.
Okay, this is a very personal goal.
I want to...
This is something I really...
Because I feel like...
I really want to motivate myself.
You know, like I've strayed away from like...
I've been more variety as of late.
But, like, I feel like I want to get back into, like, being
competitive in a way.
But not more so, like, more so, like, I want to get back
into leaderboard grinding.
But, like, not, like, forcing it on stream type deal.
I won't, like, you know, I won't be, like, stream spamming
rank all the time type deal.
But it's more so of, like, a little personal goal for
myself.
for these but like when i get close to it maybe i'll like
stream the climb the like last remaining climb to it um but
i um in uh this is this is a goal i've been thinking about a
lot in uh uh to july oh wait within a year i want to get on
the leaderboards for four different games um so this is a
little personal goal of mine uh i want to be i any for any
competitive game i want to be on a leaderboards for four
different games does they don't have to be on the same
season that's crazy but i want to do this in four different
games uh within a year so within a year uh july so on my on
next year's birthday on next year's birthday i would have
accomplished four four games four different games being on
the leaderboards and and not the leaderboards too i don't
want to touch it i want to end on the leaderboards and it's
a little personal oh hey hey dad what the fuck okay i just
felt like his nose touched my leg and it's like oh you know
like cold cold noses i was like what are you here so um
that's something i want to do so within a year okay let me
uh uh july 2025 i feel like this is so doable this is
definitely really doable and this is like a personal goal of
mine that i What?
What?
What do you want?
I have no food.
What do you... What do you want?
What do you want, Dad?
He's being... He's being needy.
I don't know where he gets it from.
She's that confident?
Okay.
All right.
I'm sorry.
But, like...
Guys, top 500 for Overwatch was master's two guys that's one
game I've already fucking can get it last season's last
season last season's top 500 for Overwatch was my I fucking
can knock that off the park
because no one look I said four different games I did say
That's why I said four.
So that's why, that's why I feel like, I feel like I can
accomplish it.
I feel like I can accomplish it.
And I feel like this is also a personal goal for myself.
Just to get back into the swing of things.
Because I haven't been able to get much into competitive
gaming.
Dad, I'm having a stream.
I don't know.
guys this is a little tmi but
okay guys okay here's a little tmi about dad he likes feet
um what do you mean by that well the reason why he's the
reason why he's barking is that is that he wanted me to
extend my and like pet him with my with my foot
so you can tell he stopped barking right
okay so this is I am king shaming him I am okay all right
anyway but he stopped barking So, these are the sacrifices
we have to make, guys.
This is the sacrifice.
This is the sacrifices we have to make.
Oh, my God.
Dad, are you serious?
Are you fucking serious?
All right.
Look, I stopped petting him.
I stopped scratching him.
So, we'll see what happens after.
Let's see what happens.
What I'm going to say?
Okay, so, other than that, Don't really have Any other goals
I don't know I don't know any goals to Oh he left Okay Okay
We're not gonna analyze that
He left Okay
Okay Um He got what he wanted.
I don't know.
I don't know what our goal is to aim for.
Other than.
Um.
Other than like.
Other than that.
Because it's like.
There's.
We already accomplished so much.
Uh.
And.
We already accomplished so much together.
Dragoons.
it's so hard to think of new things to do new things to aim
for that's why like I had that's why I had like this
personal goal of mine to have because this is my own
personal goal of mine as a competitive gamer um because like
obviously there's so much stuff going on uh behind the
scenes there's a lot stuff going on behind the scenes that
like i wasn't able to be like game in a more competitive
sense in a while like i haven't been able to like play a lot
of like fps games or like play competitive games off stream
a lot because there's just so many things going on for me uh
but i hope things start to cool down by mid-july that i can
go back i guess to my roots to my roots and uh and like you
know uh i want to have my name uh i want to have dokeybird
uh and no other name i want dokey i want uh i want dokeybird
to be like on the leaderboards being like that's that vtuber
that's that beat a vtuber on the leaderboards right there in
this game um that got there and i want to do it like on
stream too i want to get on the leaderboards on stream and
like show you guys be like look there she is on stream
getting uh getting that staying in that leaderboard
um so that's something i really want to do um i guess like i
want to get that in for like uh um for like a personal goal
of mine oh there's one there's another personal goal win
some form of vtuber award it's like um when when a cat won
some form of category in a vtuber award as dokeybird um
where's my goals list there you go that's my final goal win
a category for a vtuber award yeah I think uh that is that
is on i don't know i don't know if there's anything i want
to do um other than these um
um but i would love to win a category for a uh for a vtuber
award um doesn't matter what category i'm fine with any i
just want one
i just want one in general uh so let's just hope let's just
hope in the future At the end of the year.
Because it's almost award season.
It's almost the end of the year.
We all know what happens at the end of the year.
Every fucking award season.
So, that's hope.
Let's.
I hope that.
I hope that's possible.
I really do.
Especially as Doki.
But yeah.
I think that's really.
uh that's really like um i guess like all the things i
really want to accomplish within the year um or like not
within the year but like for my long-term goals at this
point um it's hard to think of new goals these days because
it's like i accomplish so much despite how short time i've
been around um like it's been what six months it's been
Damn, it's actually been like, it's been six months, right?
Seven months?
Has it been seven or six months?
I've honestly lost track.
Um, I've honestly, like, lost track of, um, lost track of
everything in terms of, like, time.
Five months?
It's only been five months.
Oh my God.
Has it really only been?
in five months?
That's crazy.
Oh my gosh.
I did not realize that five months has passed and like gosh,
I fucking been speedrunning.
I fucking been like speedrunning like my fucking YouTuber
career.
Dad, you're not...
Dad's parking outside my door.
Um...
yeah oh my god i it's hard to believe that it's actually
five months for for all of this happening um but like i want
to see it like uh no guys don't enable we're not here to
enable behaviors guys we're not here to enable behaviors
everybody we are here like wait you've been inside this
entire time oh my god i thought wait where were you wait
he's just he's actually been in my room this entire time
okay oh my god when did you what where were you he was
sitting behind me oh my god he was like this entire time I
didn't notice oh my god I because like when I opened the
door to like let him out he like just he like he wasn't
there so I assumed because like I didn't look down when I
opened the door I opened the door and then I waited and then
I looked down and he wasn't there so I assumed he left but
he was sitting behind me this entire time I didn't even
because then I heard the barking I was like okay fine I'm
gonna let you in like I was like fuck it I'll I fine I'm
gonna let you in.
And then I looked down and there he was in my room.
Leave.
Okay.
Now.
Now he's gone.
Now he's actually gone.
Oh my god.
He's gone for real now.
He's left the room.
Okay.
What was I saying?
God damn it, Dad.
Doki Amber Doge.
Like, he distracted me.
I don't remember what...
He distracted my conversation, my fucking topic.
I don't remember what it was on.
Um...
What was I talking about?
Fuck!
Don't blame him!
He's a good boy!
He is a good boy!
Oh, yeah.
Um.
Oh.
But yeah, it's, it's, it's crazy just to think about.
Because, like, you know.
Okay, I'm going to get mushy here.
I'm going to get mushy.
Before, because, you know, we still have to, we still have
to make a wish.
We still have to blow our candles.
I'm gonna get mushy here, guys.
I'm gonna get really mushy here.
But, you know, after everything, like, I'm gonna get a
little emotional.
A little emotional here.
But after, like, everything that happened, you know, I did
not, you know, I thought my life as a content creator was
over.
and um that really like all the hard work and like all the
effort to make guys smile and laugh would be like gone
basically uh and but i'm still here i'm still here and uh
you know like some people don't even get their like first
big break like their first lucky big break because you know
relies on a lot of luck uh i always said like to make it big
it's mostly about luck and how you capitalize on it and but
i got second i got two and if one if the one percent is
making it the first time as like your lucky big break having
the opportunity to do it a second time is like finding a con
it's like actually like the 0.0001 percent to do it a second
time and to basically have like a restart um and um is
really crazy to think about that I was able to accomplish
all of this as an indie.
Because normally you don't see indies getting these
opportunities and getting these things.
Like, I think, like, especially women, like, I guess, like,
NA slash EUVTubers.
Before me, only, like, what, Shy Lily and Shoto had
nendroids.
the indie vtubers in the western side so to be like now is
philly and i we both got nendroids now um and it's crazy to
think about because you would normally think that you know
you have to be uh under a corporate banner to be able to
achieve a lot of these things um and yeah you can say like
worked under these conditions before and you benefit from
that um but i now i'm just an indie um i don't really have
the support support structures that comes with being in the
company and um and i don't really have like you know and i
had to do a lot of this with my own team that i created uh
and being able to go through it like day by day.
That's why I've been overwhelmed a lot too behind the scenes
because it was it's a lot of work.
It's a lot.
To do it all I don't know how the other Indies do it.
But it's why I haven't been like really active.
I mean I've never really been active on like interacting on
Twitter.
So I don't know how like other big Indies interact on
Twitter a lot and like do like social media really well
when I see Shai Lily like replying to like so many tweets
and like watching and like supporting so many other VTubers
I don't know how she has all that time to do that I really
admire her because like during the skin suit skin suit debut
like day after Shai Lily message me like in support and was
like oh my god it's such an amazing debut and everything and
all that stuff and like the fact that she like took that
extra step to like you know interact with me um on like on
discord as well as like like on social media like i don't
know how she finds the time to balance all of this like she
is incredibly hard working being able to balance all of that
because i'm still learning i'm i'm i'm i'm so learning i
don't i don't know how people do this even mint mint is able
to balance so like you know like mint is able to balance
like interacting with others um in a much much much more
personal level when it comes to like um social media
interactions and like stuff with her own streams and like
her own behind the scenes work as well and i'm still
learning i'm still learning
oh my gosh it's it's a lot of work it's definitely a lot a
fun shop thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you our
happy dokey happy birthday thank you i'll accomplish so much
and we're so proud of you for all the hard work and passion
you put into your career and community six months ago did
you imagine you get this far no absolutely not i didn't even
think i was gonna get a nendroy we hope you're happy and
look forward to the future Thank you, thank you for the
Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
I hope I'll get more figures in the future.
Like, I hope I'll get a scaled figure in the future.
I didn't put in a goals list because, you know, I don't want
to ask for too much.
I already have a...
I think, like, having a Nendroid is, like, to the point
where you know you sort of made it type deal.
Because, like, um...
It's a fucking Nendroid.
Like...
That's, like...
That's, like, sort of...
of like when you know like you've sort of you've made it
like you're literally you're you're you're damn you're
that's me so that's why i didn't put scale figure because
i'm like all right i don't want to ask for too much right
here i already got that um but like i said um i couldn't
have done it without my dragoons uh for like supporting me
this far and to like take me there you know like to like uh
get me here like in my journey as a content creator and yeah
like ah okay I've done it well you guys and that's why I
like always try to include you guys as much as I can in like
different things like collabs or like merch and everything
um because like I won't be here without, you know, you can't
get far without the support of your fans and viewers.
I mean, fans, viewers.
It's the same thing, redundant.
Unless you're a hate watcher, then I guess you're a viewer.
But you know what I mean?
Like, it doesn't even matter, like, you know, super chats,
like super chats.
memberships, watching, subscribing, buying merch, all of
that stuff, getting me opportunities, like sponsor your
opportunities, getting people to invite me to conventions,
letting game companies know I exist, and like inviting me to
these opportunities and everything.
I couldn't do it without you guys.
I didn't realize how many dragoons are in like various
different avenues, like when in various companies and stuff,
like It's actually crazy finding out like there's a dragon
working in this company and like they want to sponsor me
because of that like oh my gosh like as actually It's
actually really crazy to think about sometimes Like people
in power like watch little me do dumb stuff So uh, I really
I really appreciate it.
I really I really do um
okay all right so it's time to make a birthday wish i don't
know what to wish for it but let's turn off the lights oh
wait sorry don't worry i have a remote guys i okay um guys i
have a remote control so like you see behind me you would
think behind me is like the actual outside but actually
behind me has been like a green screen this entire time so
like watch this guys I'm gonna watch this I'm gonna change
this channel on my green screen guys whoa no way yes so I
was never outside it was a green screen this entire time she
downed the Sun real yes I changed the channel dokey controls
the Sun it was a green screen this entire time never went
outside all right dragon you guys and you guys to get closer
Dragon, I need you guys to, like, move a little, shoot me a
little closer.
Okay, we're gonna put a hat here.
Okay.
We're gonna make you get a little closer.
That's right.
Come here, Dragon.
Come here.
Where did you go?
I need you to come to the, I need you to come to the table,
Dragon, and sit with us.
Us, as in, yeah, I'm gonna get Dad here, too.
Oh, wait.
Fuck, I forgot.
All right, get over here.
Where are you?
Where the fuck are you guys?
Guys, I know where did you guys go?
Where did you guys...
Where the fuck did you go?
Oh, there you go.
Okay, there we go.
And that's what you call immersion.
All right, guys.
I...
Give me a sec.
I need to grab a lighter real quick to light this cake up.
So give me a sec, guys.
I'm going to grab a lighter.
So I'm going to disappear a little bit.
And I'm going to bring Dad over too.
I'm going to bring Dad over for us.
All right.
Dad's here now too guys.
Poof.
That's how you do immersion.
Don't keep saying that's how you do immersion.
I get unimmersed.
No, I need you guys to know.
Immersion 101.
Why are you guys so low?
Because I want to feel tall.
Anyway.
Let us light up the candle.
Woo!
Alright.
Okay.
Don't tell me your wish.
But we're going to blow the candle out together.
Okay, dragons.
We're going to...
Yes, you guys don't get chairs.
Yes, we have, like, all these chairs behind us, but you
don't have the privilege to sit on a chair.
Anyway.
Anyway, guys, let's make a wish together with dad.
But don't tell me your wish or it's not going to come true.
Okay, guys, just remember, don't tell me your wish or it's
not going to come true.
Alright?
Alright, guys.
Alright.
3.
2.
1.
Wait, it's still on.
Guys.
You're supposed to help me blow it out!
Okay, we do it again.
3.
2.
1.
Yeah!
Take 2.
Guys, you're supposed to help me blow the candle out It's a
trick candle Oh my gosh What do you guys wish for?
What do you guys wish for?
We did it First try First First try First try Come on, tell
me.
Tell me, what do you guys wish for?
You can't tell her.
It's a trick.
No, come on.
Tell me.
Who said money?
All right, Aaron, you never...
Now you told my wish.
Now you told your wish.
Now you're never getting it.
Anyway.
Thank you, everybody, for coming to my birthday stream.
I hope you guys, I know it's not, you know, it's not super
elaborate.
I didn't do anything, like, super special for, like,
regarding, like, a project to celebrate the birthday.
But I just really, I'm just happy to be able to hang out
with you guys.
Just, like, talk with you guys.
And, like, and being able to, you know, just hang out and
just yap your ears off.
And just enjoy the moment.
the moment together and i feel like you know my last
birthday we had a very elaborate project going in the
skinsuit debut was a very elaborate project going in there
was not really a huge gap between me this birthday and my
last birthday so i think i deserve to take it easy for this
year i think i deserve to take it easy this year um But it
was a great time.
I'm glad to be able to spend to celebrate and announce so
many fun things.
We may not have been able to get to the final announcement.
But it is also a dream come true announcement.
And that will be revealed at a later time.
And it's another goal of mine that was accomplished.
And I'm really happy to reveal it when it's ready.
And I just want to say again, thank you everybody for coming
to the stream.
For, are you even coming to Anime Expo during the panel?
And or like, you know, waking up at 8 a.m.
to be like, what was the announcement?
But does that arrive at 8 a.m.?
Waking up at 8 a.m.
or like staying up really late?
uh to like see what the announcement was uh you're saying
thank you guys um and thank you for uh being there and uh
yes by the way the biggest hype thing yes nendroin anyway um
as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and
move around to get that blood flowing and if you sit up for
me Head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.